gilbert the 24 year old right-hander
making his ninth start of the year 2-2
record a 4-2-5 era
and in 36 innings he has 39 strikeouts
over just eight blocks
so right away two down for the rangers
here in the top of the first inning and
that'll bring up center fielder dolis
garcia who's having a great year
big psy up on the mound now the wind-up
and the one-two on the way fastball
swing and a miss strike three got him
with a 98 mile an hour heater
kyle gibson the rangers
always excited when they have kyle out
there they feel like that gives them
their best chance to win anager 1 for 10
against kyle gibson in that one hit a
home run
the one-two pitch is on the way and he
struck him out swinging
change speeds there to get hannigan
that's the second out of the inning
gibson is not a strikeout pitcher per se
he's one of the few pitchers who's well
under a strikeout for inning for the
year 75 strikeouts
in 91 innings for kyle and with two outs
and no score here's kyle senior against
kyle gibson
one ball two strikes
the pitch to seeger
swing in the miss he struck him out
curveball got him so a one two three
inning for gibson and we head to the
second rangers nothing mariners nothing
leading to the off designated hitter
joey gallo as we go to the top half of
the second leading it off designated
hitter joey gallo here's the wind-up and
the 2-2 on the way strike three called
got him looking with a fastball
down around the knees strike on number
two for gilbert
swinging a miss
gilbert's rolling three consecutive
strikeouts two swinging and that brings
up jake bowers the first baseman
powers acquired from the cleveland
indians
on june the 10th for a player to be
named later he's filling in at first for
the injured evan white
bowers with the two teams combined
hitting 226 but since coming to seattle
he's hitting 279.
well that's right on the inside corner
bowers down looking third strikeout for
gibson and this is about as perfect of a
front door two seamer as you can throw
watch this pitch to bowers it's going to
start in off the plate a little bit of
late movement just to catch the corner
when he's making a move like that on the
corners forget about it there's a swing
of the miss and he strikes out terence
that's four strikeouts for gibson
through the first two innings
second and third now with one out back
to the top of the order and brock holt
up the middle that's a base hit one one
is in here comes culverson the throw to
the play not in time
two runs score and now heading to second
base is holt
and they waste no time
in taking advantage of the error and the
opening and the rangers strike for two
take a look at brock holt right here on
a fastball second time around seeing
this fastball this one is located down
he goes and gets it just out of the
reach of shedlong jr and the excellent
base running here from the rangers pays
off that is a very nice job by charlie
culverson all the way around you can see
solace scoring easily and then charlie
way ahead of the throw and logan gilbert
was not where he was supposed to be
texas on top two nothing in the fifth
inning
and the batter will be charlie culberson
this one past third base that's inside
the line will be extra bases solace got
off to a good start they send him to the
plate and he'll score without a throw
culverson with the rbi double and it's
three nothing rangers
it's been a good inning for charlie
culverson he made that great defensive
play now here he is out in front
of an off-speed pitch looked like a
curveball
you see him hooking it and you're also
going to see this baseball kind of got
stuck and look like not stuck but just
settled in
down the left field line up against the
wall nick solak looks like he's wearing
his dad's helmet his two boys coming
down
in front of his eyes
two balls two strikes two outs runner at
second
bouncing ball shed long
hangs fires get enough arm no bowers
here's a throw to the plane
it's in time to get culverson
culverson was trying to score from
second long was way out there in right
field with a shift on he had to go way
to his right the long throw the first
was late trying to get low culverson
kept right on coming powers alertly
fired to the plate to terence terence
down with a tag to get culverson at home
plate and that will retire the side
jake fraley
only looking to ignite something against
kyle gibson who's on top of his game
tonight
high flag ball right field got a chance
looking up gallow
bubba
jake friendly with his first home run
here team over park and america on the
board it's 3-1 here in the fifth
good for jake fraley home run number
seven rbi number 20 finally got one here
at home
that's such a good approach at the plate
here's the change up 83 miles an hour
towering fly ball literature it was
going to carry but it certainly does
exit fee low of 101 381 feet his seventh
home run
oh nice catch so kyle against kyle here
in a big moment in the fifth inning
crawford the runner out at second base
o2 pitch to seeger and he hits this one
on the ground to first base low will
take care of it himself the inning
is done best in the american league is
really turned things around 3-1 rangers
top seven
here comes freely got a super jump super
jumped by jake fell he had it all the
way
well done two down into seven
and there you go looks like it was going
to drop out there but he covers a lot of
ground too great jump
a tremendous speed making the diving
catch concentration all the way a pretty
good slide after he hits the ground
opportunity here for kyle seeger and the
mariners down 3-1 tying runs on base
kyle represents the go ahead run
here comes your one
hit hard right in the first baseman
he'll get the middle runner
martin that ball gets away sega's going
to be safe at first j.p crawford scores
he got a 3-2 ball game
and that'll bring up catcher luis
terence
[Applause]
now is the lead off man and being super
productive they need a moment from him
right here
but in play yes sir here
comes
the throw to the plate
not in time the man
the heroin game
center field deep to center field off
the wall
here comes white
he will score
and the rangers have tied it up at four
in the ninth
one out
tenth inning 4-4 score jake fraley a
chance to win this one
that's gonna do it your ball game
jake fraley what a night mariners win
this baby 5-4